[Musik]
das wahre Leben ist sich für andere
einzusetzen wir die Pflegefachkräfte von
morgen mit kogniturl der Versicherer für
Gesundheit und Vorsorge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vielleicht rettet Ihnen eine vor deiner
jungen Mannschaft
sie sind Orgien die Flagge von Kraft
oder rettichsanitäterin dieselbe
strangend
[Musik]
wir die Pflegefachkräfte von morgen
ist gut danke
bewusstlos ist und die Hexe verletzter
rechte Hand gut
Verletzungen
was ist los was ist passiert also ich
bin da also steht am vorgesetzt
mit Spezialisten für Handchirurgie wenn
es ist passiert 20 Minuten okay gut
zum Auto das geht schneller als mit
einer tragbaren danke
okay hast ja Allergien
ich weiß nicht kann ich eine leider
nicht sagen tut mir leid das muss fragen
aber hätte noch einmal gesehen
[Musik]
schlimm Verletzungen
sehr gut
gemacht mir ist ganz wichtig ist gut
[Musik]
oh Gott oh das hat nicht richtig klar
das ist passiert
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Studierenden ist das die größte
Hochschul für Pflegefachkräfte der
Schweiz Bus bilden
Z möglichst schnell ein venöser Zugang
es ist zwar nur ein plastikraum aber man
hat er nur mit 3 Minuten
dringend wiederbelebt werden muss alles
ganz genau zu etwas
Ellen hat's wichtigste vergasse Spritze
Berlin
Universität
verlieren aber wenn er das ständig seid
dann geht's noch mehr
konzentrieren genau
hat als Praktikantin immer wieder müsse
Venenkatheter legen aber noch nie
besondere Notfallsituation
jetzt muss man nur noch schlüchli
Anschlüsse telen ist nicht schnell genug
30 Sekunden
[Musik]
ganz schlecht in der wird kompliziert
und das hangelt
es braucht
Druck
handelt oftmal unlogisch
[Musik]
ihres Praktikum abgeschlossen und werdet
immer eine Spital ist
es sicher besonders
[Musik]
wir sind im Spital troschan in gansätze
Praktikumswoche im geriatrischen
Notfalldienst zieht dass der Luka
sichelei um einen Patient
kümmertaufnahmen
[Musik]
notfallparkplatz rund um dort ein
Krankenwagen nach einem anderen der
Genre ist ein klemmt sind Frau wo sich
so stimmt ist auch im Spital darum ist
der 83-Jährige Station
37,8
das ist beunruhigen Werten
auf jeden Fall
weniger Vertreter Temperatur
so der Herr sie sind jetzt im Bett wir
machen sogar noch bequemer
jetzt muss man nur als Zimmer finden
aber oft Abteilung sind alle Betten
besetzt
[Musik]
machen
Delica ist genauso gestresst wie der
Patient
ja ja wählen weniger Patient
heute die Menschen
mache doch bitte mal
ganz fest zusammendrücken bitte sehr gut
wenn ich ein stechen können
es ist ganz gut
ganz kurz immerhin aber ganz wenig
falsch machen was nicht aufgeschmissen
fertig
es ist schon sehr frustrierend
und menschliche Qualitäten
wunderbar
es telefonisch
ja genau
jetzt kann der Genre Frau informieren wo
immer andere Spital ist
sie schwindischen so stark wenn es
[Musik]
das
Personen neugierig sie will wissen wohin
drüber lustigsten
total wichtig ja nicht gern ohne das
lenkt mir als ich meine
diskutieren und meinen Schlafmützen
[Musik]
ja bis dann
ganz genau aufschreiben
sehr kompliziert
wieder unterwegs
[Musik]
Grüße
zurück
[Musik]
wir müssen Euch trotzdem
[Applaus]
kein Problem
der Punkt ist mit einer alkoholisiert
wo Medikament knochend
[Musik]
komplett ausflippt man weiß es nicht
ja
im Moment kooperativ
funny informierte Spital aber sie wollte
Patienten provozieren und nicht vor
alkoholvergiftig sondern braucht die
medizinisch Abkürzung
amelie ist klar dass Situation jede
Moment kann eskalieren aber mache sie
nicht viel
er hat merkt dass es immer immer mehr
beruhigen und im gut zu Ende
Situationen
psychologische wo entscheidet ummeno
Empathie
nachher 8-minütigen Fahrt mit mulmigem
Gefühl und Ambulanz endlich im
Notfallort davon ist es gelungen
sehr gut Geld zum laufen wir müssen dort
hingehen
[Musik]
alles klar kommen
wieder Abfahrt sind es nur ziemlich
gespannt
[Musik]
im Universitätsspital Genf treffen
Ausbildungsjahr und macht es Praktikum
in der Abteilung für Viszeralchirurgie
[Musik]
guten Morgen
Wunsch und ich so ja klar
ja minuswerke ja jetzt müsste
80-jährig hat man operieren
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hat den künstlichen Darmausgang mit dem
kümmern
mit seiner später tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
das mit der Fernbedienung vom Bett ist
eigentlich kompliziert logistisch
[Musik]
also respektvoll
aber vor allem das muss
womit 80
[Musik]
für Viszeralchirurgie vom
Universitätsspital Genf fangt
[Musik]
und das da das ist valium und zwar 10 mg
aufsichtigt flagge-
und wenn man am Computer sitzt und
Informationen
[Gelächter]
ja doch
offensichtlich
und darum jetzt nicht mehr gehabt
[Musik]
und sympathisch und locker einfach total
erklärt
iert
[Gelächter]
gute Nacht
bitte noch zehn Flagge fachlüht auf
Sicherheit gestellt ein Arzt oder ein
Ärztin die im Notfall telefonisch
erreichbar
und schlafe ist nicht erlaubt darum
verbringt große Teil von der Nacht im
Stationszimmer tätisches ruhig und
machen
und mit dem EFZ abgeschlossen und zwar
ihr Erfolg
und sich überall alles
so gut gefallen will
[Gelächter]
was ich gemacht habe und dass ich aus
dem Gesundheitsbericht komme
aber repariert
es ist
wir machen alle zwei Stunden rund die es
gibt Patienten wo auch in der
nachttabletten brauchen
immer genau kontrollieren ob alles
überall passt
[Applaus]
ich selber schlafen nicht
andere schlafen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Blutkontrolle macht mir so früh am
Morgen damit Labor knurrt hat zum sie
auswerten am lüne ist Arztvisite
Schichtwechsel im Stationszimmer Gott zu
uns Stock Rebecca übergeht alle
Informationen vor ihren Patienten der
Kolleginnen und jetzt übernimmt er
braucht immer nur
motivieren
das mit dem Arzt noch sagen
alles andere wird ja eh neu besprochen
in der nächsten Folge in ihrem letzten
Praktikum und beweist Fürsorglichkeit
[Musik]
erst mal leitet
sie versucht laberformen
[Musik]
und Rebecca hat dir die Ausbildung
abgeschlossen und findet wieder Post
[Musik]
Personen
das war wir die Pflegefachkräfte von
morgen mit kognituell der Versicherer
für Gesundheit und Vorsorge